well first and foremost this might be
the first time that rich piscatchia is
in the head coaching seat but i'll tell
you what he's been around the game for
quite some time 40 total years spent
coaching 20 in the nfl of course winning
that super bowl ring in 2003 with the
then oakland raiders so i think the
organization has complete confidence and
trust with him in this interim head
coaching position and as far as how this
will impact the team moving forward well
it can go one of two ways right the
locker room can split or it can unite
and being around this team for as long
as i have i think it's going to be the
latter these guys refer to each other as
family and i think that they're going to
use this as motivation moving forward
well you can't rule anything out at this
point but it seems like it's still too
early to tell if there might have a
ripple effect within the management or
coaching staff of course when your head
coach does resign surrounding these
circumstances
anything is possible